Javier Castillo is learning how to use a
gun and says that after just a few
lessons she's mastering how to hold aim
and fire a weapon
she never dreamed of acquiring such a
skill until she and her boyfriend became
victims of rising crime in Chile
it was terrifying they stole our vehicle
at gunpoint I was left in shock I was
afraid to go out at night
statistically Chile remains one of the
safest countries in a very unsafe region
but in a country where armed robberies
and murders were once rare violent crime
has soared in the last few years
you can tell that people are looking
over their shoulders a lot more than
they used to according to official
figures murder has gone up 33 percent
violent robberies 63 percent and
kidnappings which was something
absolutely unheard of in Chile up until
very recently by 77 according to the
government much of this violence has
been imported for example drive-by
robberies or murders on motorcycles this
and even more gruesome forms of crime
has turned this type of violence into
the number one concern for the vast
majority of Chileans
in April three policemen were shot dead
in the line of duty
Chileans took to the streets to demand
radical measures to combat crime and
protect police
under Fierce pressure the left-wing
government signed a controversial law on
April 6 that gives police the right to
use lethal Force if necessary under the
presumption of innocence
unlike before the onus is now on the
victim or family members to prove that
police abuse their power
it's been nicknamed the trigger-happy
law by critics including Amnesty
International and other human rights
organizations
the only thing the law does is increase
the possibility of human rights
violations being committed as well as
increasing impunity by state agents when
they commit abuses against citizens
already a number of policemen who are
under investigation for abuse of power
and violence have had their cases
dropped since the law is retroactive
but for now that's not the main concern
for most ordinary citizens who hope that
unlike in many neighboring countries
crime will not become just another
normal part of life
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Santiago